[Applause]
novak djokovic has repeatedly spoken out
in the past two weeks
against the decision by the australian
open organisers
to quarantine players ahead of the
tournament but in front of the almost
seven and a half thousand fans allowed
in to watch at melbourne park
with trophy in hand it seemed as if all
was forgiven
look there are a lot of mixed feelings
about what has happened in
the last month or so with tennis players
coming to australia
but i think when we draw a line in the
end it was a successful tournament for
organizers djokovic hadn't lost in 17
appearances in semi-finals and finals at
the australian open
his opponent daniel medvedev hadn't lost
to anyone since october
but the world number one showed his
intent from the very start
in the second set the pressure proved
too much for the russian
nine grand slams in australia 18 total
is amazing and probably it's not your
last one so i mean
i have no words to say uh it's a matter
of time
when you're going to hold the grand slam
that's for sure
if you don't mind waiting few more years
djokovic has won six of the last ten
majors and is now just
two wins away from joining roger federer
and rafael nadal
with the men's all-time overall record
of 20 grand slam titles
the one in melbourne guarantees he'll
stay world number one until at least
march 8th
that'll be 311 weeks in the top spot
and that breaks another of federer's
records
paul vanderworth al jazeera